the purpose of the university it's based
upon free speech free inquiry the open
exchange of ideas it is an on-ground
campus
and right now this inseriousness in
traditional academic institutions is an
and i i think it's really important to
call things what it is it's not the
liberals who have taken over the
institutions it's the authoritarians who
have taken over the institutions
traditional academic institutions so
this is not a conservative university
this is a university like hillsdale for
example would be a conservative
university to have a conservative slant
uh victor david hanson teaches there
conservative professors this has people
from all over the intellectual political
moral spectrum
and when i say intellectual spectrum i
mean they publish different things
scholarly outlooks different
epistemologies
different ways to approach problems and
it's needed because our institutions now
have been hijacked by maniacs the
process of accreditation takes some time
and what they're doing now is they're
having this forbidden courses program
and they're getting the wheels greased
they're getting faculty members they're
putting the institution together and
they're also buying
from i'm not involved in any of these
decisions but my understanding they're
they're buying a considerable amount of
land as well and so these are just like
pilot programs the first forays into the
arena and as the university advances and
matures so too will things like the
accreditation follow the credibility
and
i would urge people to look at the
credentials and the gravitas former
presidents of harvard university of the
aclu
ten i mean the it's truly a who's who in
the academic world
and
the those the gravitas of those
folks stephen pinker i mean so many
people are part of the of the university
institution it's easy to kind of throw
out a comparison it's very difficult to
build something and to make something i
think it's a it genuinely is a place
where
where
please remain seated people debate ideas
from all over the political spectrum
people have honest conversations and
they don't feel like they have to walk
on eggshells and they can substantively
engage controversial issues in fact the
first thing that's coming
to the on ground campus is the forbidden
topics courses and they're going to have
classes in which nobody else will teach
and nobody else will talk about it but i
think it's really important if i if i
may say something they're not just going
to throw students in the water in the
deep end and just expect them to swim so
i'm going to teach in the beginning part
of that i wrote the book how to have
impossible conversations
most of my scholastic work is on the
socratic method
conversations conversations across gulfs
and divides how do we improve critical
thinking and reasoning moral reasoning
skills so i'm going to go and teach the
beginnings and talk about okay what do
you do if you hear an idea that's
offensive how do you ask the right
questions how do you navigate these
things so nobody is thrown in the deep
end and just expect it to float we're
going to give them a road map and a
pathway to ask better questions and what
to do when they're confronted by ideas
they they they might never hear or they
may be shocked by one one uh fellow even
said i'm
caught in an insane asylum everybody's
gone crazy i will work for half the
other people that's another thing people
are saying not only do they want to go
to to what pano and
and and uh well i actually put myself in
this group if i may uh and and we are
trying to do here the the
university they're actually gonna work
for
less money than they're making they're
desperate to get out they can't stand
the liberalism they can't stand the
censoriousness they can't stand the
diversity statements that they can't
stand pretending to believe something
that not only do they not believe they
just know it's false but they can't do
anything about it unless they receive
accusations of bigotry or discrimination
unfortunately now philosophy has been
again to be very blunt with you it's
been hijacked by ideologues and i'm
interested in
a genuine engagement of an idea i'm
interested in the socratic tradition in
the socratic project and yeah it's true
it's true he killed socrates at times he
wasn't
he's a very unpopular fellow but he
asked the hard questions he asked
questions that we had to ask and those
questions are just absolutely
indispensable for an education and
you're not finding those questions being
asked in traditional universities in
fact
professors are coming into the class
with answers and they're coming into the
class with answers to moral questions
that comport with a single
uh moral orthodoxy something that's very
morally fashionable now that does the
the students a tremendous disservice it
does the people who are paying tuition a
tremendous disservice and i want
absolutely no part of that whatsoever i
want to maintain my integrity
it's very easy
to
both look at the extreme cases of
wokism and the extreme cases of
ideological capture and even the
moderate cases of ideological capture
but what people don't look at it is
that this ideology has penetrated so
many institutions
and venerable institutions too the aclu
the splc
it's in the military now it's in
it's in
medicine it's in our main medical
journals right now we know the source of
this we know the origination point and
it's the universities the university's
wholesale and this is a sweeping
statement and it's also true are doing
students an injustice and it's not
enough
that those of us who are against this
authoritarianism and a liberal
sensoriousness sit around and scream
about it all day we have to build
something we have to give people an
alternative and that alternative should
not be a a conservative alternative or a
libertarian alternative that should be a
genuine diversity of opinion so we come
and we bring in the best people to talk
about the best ideas on different sides
of the coin and we give students a road
map and a way to understand and make
sense of those questions and then they
decide this isn't an indoctrination mill
this is what a university should be